BUT FIRST, WHY THE LEFT LIES.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
DEMOCRATS HAVE REACHED I THINK
THE OBVIOUS CONCLUSION THAT
THEIR ONLY PATH, SURE PATH TO
VICTORY, IS THE BURN IT ALL DOWN
APPROACH OF THE NEO-BOLSHEVIKS
ON THE STREETS.
JOE BIDEN’S TEAM HAS FORMED
COMMON CAUSE WITH THOSE WHO NOT
ONLY SEEK THE DESTRUCTION OF THE
NUCLEAR FAMILY.
IF YOU DON’T BELIEVE ME, CHECK
OUT BLM’S WEBSITE.
THEY’VE ACTUALLY DECIDED THAT
PROMOTING RACIAL HATRED IS THE
ONLY WAY THEY CAN WIN.
IF THEY KNOW THAT TRUMPS
POLICIES, IT’S OBVIOUS, HAVE
DELIVERED RESULTS FOR WORKING
PEOPLE OF ALL RACES WHILE
THERE IS HAVE LARGELY FAILED.
THE LEFT HOPES THAT THE RACIAL
DIVISION AND THE HIDING THEIR
CANDIDATE, THEY CAN AVOID A REAL
DEBATE ON THE ISSUE.
OVER THE WEEKEND, THE PRESIDENT
RESPONDED WITH TWO POWERFUL
SPEECHES TO CELEBRATE OUR
INDEPENDENCE AND IDENTIFY THE
DOMESTIC FORCES NOW THREATENING
IT.
HIS REMARKS ON MOUNT RUSHMORE
REAFFIRMED AMERICA’S IDENTITY
AND INSPIRED MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS WHO’VE BASICALLY BEEN
LIVING IN DESPAIR BECAUSE OF THE
ONE-TWO PUNCH OF THE VIRUS AND
THE CONTINUING RIOTS.
>> THESE RADICALS WOULD TEAR
DOWN THE VERY HERITAGE FOR WHICH
MEN GAVE THEIR LIVES TO WIN THE
CIVIL WAR.
THEY WOULD TEAR DOWN THE
PRINCIPLES THAT PROPELLED THE
ABOLITIONISM OF SLAVERY.
AND ULTIMATELY AROUND THE WORLD,
BENDING AND EVIL INSTITUTION THA
PLAGUED HUMANITY FOR THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF YEARS.
OUR OPPONENTS WOULD TEAR APART
THE VERY DOCUMENTS THAT
MARTIN LUTHER KING USED TO
EXPRESS HIS DREAM.
THEY WOULD TEAR DOWN THE
BELIEFS, CULTURE, AND IDENTITY
THAT HAVE MADE AMERICA THE MOST
VIBRANT AND TOLERANT SOCIETY IN
THE HISTORY OF THE EARTH.
WE’VE ALL PROCLAIMED THE IDEALS
OF THE DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE AND WE WILL NEVER
SURRENDER THIS.
AND THE COURAGE AND THE CAUSE
OF JULY 4TH.
1776.
UPON THIS GROUND, WE WILL STAND
FIRM AND UNWAVERING.
IN THE FACE OF LIES, MEANT TO
DIVIDE US, DEMORALIZE US, AND
DIMINISH US.
>> Laura: NOW YOU CAN ALWAYS
TELL HOW EFFECTIVE ONE OF THE
PRESIDENT’S SPEECH IT IS BY
HOUSE FRENZIED THE REACTION FROM
LIBERALS.
>> I ACTUALLY THOUGHT IT WAS
SOME FANTASY.
>> HE’S DESPERATE TO.
>> THERE WAS A LOT ABOUT
HISTORY, GOD, OUR GREAT COUNTRY.
MUCH OF A VERY OMINOUS.
>> THERE WAS NO ATTEMPT HERE TO
UNIFY THE COUNTRY.
IT WAS A DIVISIVE MESSAGE.
>> THE PRESIDENT THREW DOWN THE
CULTURAL WAR GAUNTLET IN DEFENSE
OF DEAD WHITE MEN.
>> YOU REALIZE HOW DISTURBED AND
HOW DISTURBING THIS PRESIDENT
REALLY IS.
>> Laura: I DESCRIBE LIBERALS
AND K-6 AND JENNIFER RUBIN ARE
AMONG THEM, YOU BET.
IF LYING WAS AN OLYMPIC SPORT,
THESE FOLKS WOULD BE DRAPED IN
GOLD MEDALS.
IN MOMENTS OF RARE CANDOR, THEY
KNOW THAT TRUMP BEATS BIDEN
HANDS DOWN ON JOBS, WAGES FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
TRUMP BEATS BIDEN ON EDUCATION.
HE FAVORS LIBERATION FOR PARENTS
AND STUDENTS WHO ARE STUCK IN
BAD SCHOOLS.
TRUMP BEAT BIDEN ON PRISON
REFORM.
OBAMA AND BIDEN BOTH TALKED A
GOOD GAME.
THEY DIDN’T GET IT DONE.
AND OF COURSE TRUMP HAS DONE
SOMETHING THAT BIDEN NEVER DID.
HE HAS ACTUALLY HIRED AND
PROMOTED AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND
OTHER MINORITIES ACROSS HIS MANY
BUSINESSES.
WERE BIDEN AND DEMOCRATS ARE
CONTENT TO PATRONIZE
AFRICAN-AMERICANS WITH THESE
MEANINGLESS SYMBOLIC GESTURES,
CONSERVATIVES ACTUALLY BELIEVE
THAT MINORITIES WANT WHAT ALL
PEOPLE WANT: A FAIR CHANCE AT
PROSPERITY AND TO PURSUE THEIR
HAPPINESS AND FREEDOM AND
SAFETY.
TRUMP KNOWS THIS IS ONLY
POSSIBLE WITH VIBRANT, GROWING
ECONOMY WHERE ALL CRIMINALS ARE
PROSECUTED.
MEANWHILE, BIDEN THINKS HE CAN
SURF TO VICTORY ON RACIAL ANGER,
STOKED BY MOBS, MANY OF WHOM ARE
WHITE, WHO WOULD RATHER SEE
EVERY CITY IN AMERICA BURN THEN
A SECOND TRUMP TERM.
NOW, THIS REQUIRES A MASSIVE
EFFORT TO LIE AND DEFAME.
ONE THAT AN HONEST PRESS WOULD
HAVE EXPOSED LONG AGO.
AS I’VE SAID BEFORE, INSTEAD OF
COVERING THE DEMOCRATS, THE
MEDIA COVER FOR THEM.
THEIR TACTICS AND THEIR TOXIC
ASSOCIATIONS, I’M TALKING ABOUT.
SO LONG AS THE END GAME OF ANY
ACTIVIST OR POLITICIAN IS TO RID
AMERICA OF TRUMP, THE PRESS WILL
EXCUSE ALL MANNER OF FALSEHOOD,
HYPOCRISY, AND EVEN CRIMINALITY.
SO TO STOKE RACIAL TENSION, THE
BIDEN CAMPAIGN REQUIRES A
MASSIVE EFFORT TO LIE AND DEFAME
ONE THAT WOULD HAVE ALREADY BEEN
EXPOSED LONG AGO.
WHEN YOU THINK BACK, WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT HOW THIS WHOLE THING
WENT DOWN, HOW DID IT GO DOWN?
IT WENT DOWN AFTER THIS LONG
SHUTDOWN.
PEOPLE HAD A LOT OF TIME ON
THEIR HANDS.
AGAIN, IF WE CONTINUE TO ALLOW
THESE LIES AND THIS ONGOING
SLANDER AND DEFAMATION TO
CONTINUE, WELL, WHAT HAPPENS?
PEOPLE WILL CONTINUE TO LOSE
FAITH IN THE SYSTEM OF LAW AND
EVEN IN EQUAL PROTECTION.
>> LOOTERS GOT A BAD NAME DURING
THE GEORGE FLOYD PROTESTS.
BUT THANK GOODNESS FOR THE
LOOTERS.
YOU HAVE A PLACE CALLED TARGET.
YOU HAVE A STORE CALLED TARGET.
YOU’RE GOING TO BE A TARGET.
THESE PLACES HAVE ABSENTLY
CONTRIBUTED TO THE OPPRESSION.
>> Laura: NOW, THE LEFT IS
EVEN TRYING TO GET THE BROADWAY
SENSATION "HAMILTON" CANCELED.
IF YOU THINK THAT’S A WACKY, IT
IS.
THAT’S RIGHT, THERE’S THAT
CANCEL "HAMILTON" HASHTAG OUT
THERE.
NEVER MIND THAT ALL THE KEY
ROLES, GO TO THOSE OF ALEXANDER
HAMILTON AND GEORGE WASHINGTON
ARE PLAYED BY PEOPLE OF COLOR IN
THE MUSICAL, CRITICS SAY GLOSSES
OVER KEY FACTS.
THEY CLAIM HAMILTON WAS NOT AN
ABOLITIONIST AND TRADED SLAVES
FOR HIS IN-LAWS.
THE MERE FACT THAT IT CELEBRATES
THE FOUNDING ERA IN ANY POSITIVE
WAY, TO GOOD MUSIC, IS AMPLE
REASON FOR THE LEFT TO CALL FOR
ITS CANCELLATION.
NOW, THE ONLY THING AT THIS
POINT THAT IS SACRED TO THEM IS
THE NOTION THAT IF YOU ARE A
LEFTIST, YOU CANNOT BE
QUESTIONED OR PROSECUTED FOR
CRIMES.
YEAH.
AND JUSTIFY THE MEANS, YOU BET
THEY DO.
PAST GRIEVANCES MEANS NEVER
HAVING TO SAY YOU’RE SORRY.
THAT MEDIA WILL GIVE YOU A PASS
FOR ANYTHING.
AT THE SAME TIME, THEY SPY
RACISM ARE OUT EVERY CORNER.
>> JUSSIE SMOLLETT SAYS HE WAS
ASSAULTED BY TWO MASKED MEN WHO
YELLED OUT RACIAL AND HOMOPHOBIC
SLURS.
POLICE ARE INVESTIGATING THE
INCIDENT AS A POSSIBLE
HATE CRIME.
>> A HORRIFYING RACIST INCIDENT.
>> HEINOUS, HEINOUS.
>> UGLY.
>> CRUDE AND COWARDLY.
>> NASCAR IS INVESTIGATING A
HORRIBLE INCIDENT.
>> A NOOSE WAS FOUND IN THE
GARAGE STALL OF BUBBLE WALLACE.
>> NASCAR MAY TRY TO DISTANCE
ITSELF FROM IT, IT’S A LIVING
PART OF THE SPORT.
>> Laura: TRUMP TRIES TO CALL
HIM ON IT AND THEN HE BECOMES
THE TARGET.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THE
PRESIDENCIES RACISM IS A
POTENTIAL PATH TO REELECTION?
>> THERE IS NO DOUBT AND I HAVE
SAID IT BEFORE, THIS PRESIDENT,
HIS POLITICAL CALCULUS IS ALL
ABOUT DIVISION, NOT ADDITION.
>> Laura: WHY DOES THE LEFT DO
ALL OF THIS?
WELL, IT’S SIMPLE.
TO DEFLECT FROM THE DEMOCRATS
OWN HORRIFIC RECORD ON RACE,
THE ECONOMY, AND CRIME.
>> THIS IS NOW A THIRD WEEK IN A
ROW OR WE’VE SEEN CHILDREN SHOT
AND KILLED HERE.
>> PART OF A WEEK AND WILL
RESOLVE MORE THAN 60 PEOPLE SHOT
AND OVER A DOZEN PEOPLE KILLED.
>> POINT BLANK.
WHAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW?
>> THE ECOSYSTEM OF PUBLIC
SAFETY THAT ISN’T JUST
LAW-ENFORCEMENT BUT IT’S LOCAL,
COMMUNITY-BASED, THEY TOO HAVE
REALLY BEEN HIT HARD BY COVID
AND ARE NOW JUST KIND OF COMING
BACK ONLINE AND GETTING THEIR
FOOTING.
>> Laura: WHAT?
DID YOU HEAR THAT?
CHICAGO HAS SEEN A TRAGIC LEVEL
OF VIOLENCE SINCE THE BLACK
LIVES MATTER MARCHES STARTED AND
IT’S CLAIMING AFRICAN-AMERICAN
LIVES AND COSTING THE VAST
TRICKLE BLACK COMMUNITY DEARLY.
THE BAD GUYS AREN’T THE FOLKS
GOING TO MOUNT RUSHMORE.
THEY ARE CRIMINALS MURDERING
CHILDREN ON THE STREETS OF OUR
NATION’S THIRD-LARGEST CITY.
80 PEOPLE WERE SHOT, 17 KILLED
IN CHICAGO LAST WEEK?
WEEKEND ALONE.
AT LEAST 13 OF THOSE WERE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN.
IT GETS EVEN MORE TRAGIC.
INCLUDE BEING AMONG THE DEAD,
7-YEAR-OLD, NATALIA WALLACE.
SHE WAS SHOT IN THE HEAD.
SHE WAS VISITING HER GRANDMOTHER
FOR THE FOURTH OF JULY.
SADLY, SHE WASN’T THE ONLY CHILD
KILLED.
IN SOUTHEAST D.C., 11-YEAR-OLD
YVONNE McNEIL, SHOT AND KILLED
ON THE A FOURTH OF JULY COOKOUT
WITH HIS FAMILY.
ARMED THUGS IN ATLANTA MURDERED
E-YEAR-OLD SECORIEA TURNER NEAR
THE WENDY’S WHERE RAYSHARD
BROOKS DIED AT THE HANDS OF
POLICE.
THIS IS SENSELESS AND AWFUL
KILLING AND IT’S OBVIOUSLY LEFT
HER PARENTS HEARTBROKEN,
SHATTERED, AND ASKING WHY.
>> THEY SAY BLACK LIVES MATTER.
THEY KILLED MY BABY BECAUSE SHE
CROSSED A BARRIER TO MAKE A
U-TURN.
SHE KILLED THE CHILD.
SHE DIDN’T KNEW NOTHING TO
NOBODY.
>> Laura: EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THESE CITIES IS RUN BY DEMOCRATS
AND RATHER THAN DRESSING VIOLENT
CRIME, DRUGS, FATHERLESSNESS,
PLAGUING SO MANY COMMUNITIES,
THEY JUST MAKE EXCUSES.
THEY THROW OUT PHRASES LIKE
SYSTEMIC RACISM, UNCONSCIOUS
BIAS, OR WHITE PRIVILEGE AND
MINIMIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY,
LOVE OF ONE’S NEIGHBOR, AND THE
VALUE OF EVERY HUMAN LIFE.
SO RATHER THAN INSISTING ON LAW
AND ORDER, SAFETY IN EVERY
COMMUNITY, INCLUDING
AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITIES,
THIS IS THE BEST THEY CAN OFFER.
>> WE TALK ABOUT SYSTEMIC RACISM
AND THE TRAUMA.
YOU THINK ABOUT THE LEADERSHIP
OR THE LACK THEREOF THAT WE HAVE
COMING FROM THE HIGHEST OFFICE
IN THE LAND, I THINK THAT YOU
ARE SEEING SO MANY EMOTIONS PLAY
OUT AND TOO OFTEN IT’S PLAYING
OUT IN OUR STREETS.
>> Laura: EMOTIONS ARE PLAYING
OUT?
I THINK SOME FOLKS ARE STILL
TRYING TO PRETEND THAT ALL OF
THIS MAYHEM WILL STOP IF WE JUST
LET THE DEMOCRATS HAVE THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WE HAVE THE DEMOCRATS IN AND
POWER IN ATLANTA, CHICAGO,
NEW YORK, BALTIMORE AND BEYOND A
BEYOND.
WHAT HAPPENED?
THE THINKING IS FOOLISH AND
NAIVE.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE SHOWN THEY
ARE UTTERLY UNWILLING TO
RESTRAIN THE HARD LEFT FROM
SEIZING PROPERTY AND COMMITTING
VIOLENCE.
AS FOR THE CULTURE WARS, WHY
WITH THE RADICAL STOP WHEN THEY
THINK THEY ARE WINNING.
IGNORE THE FOLKS WHO SAY IT GETS
BETTER WHEN WE LET THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE MORE POWER.
THE ONLY WAY THIS SITUATION GETS
BETTER IS FOR DEMOCRATS TO LOSE
AND LOSE SO OFTEN THAT THEY ARE
FORCED TO APOLOGIZE FOR THEIR
RELENTLESS SLANDERING OF OUR
NATIONS HISTORY AND BY
EXTENSION, THE MAJORITY OF OUR
CITIZENS WHO STILL ON